[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul aka the guy who's
about to go full-on beast mode as we
break down the ending of transformers
warfare cybertron trilogy
kingdom is finally here and it wraps up
the saga in pretty fitting fashion
whilst leaving the door open for the
future and further netflix spin-offs
also i kind of wish that they'd been on
amazon so we could have done some amazon
prime jokes
but this is pretty much what we're stuck
with and let's be honest it's not like i
have good material anyway
now in this video we're going to be
breaking down the overall plot
and giving our thoughts on where things
could be going for the future
bull spoilers ahead so don't be a
ratchet and make sure you prune yourself
from the timeline if you don't want
anything ruined
smash the thumbs up button if you're not
a resistor and make sure you subscribe
for videos like this each and every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into transformers
okay so the third chapter in the trilogy
picks up in the prehistoric age of earth
our heroes and villains have both
crash-landed on the planet
and here they come face to face with the
characters from beast wars
the series so far has kind of felt a lot
like a greatest hits compilation of the
transformers story
and outside of these we of course met
the quintessons last time
much like the all spark the series gives
you visions of what you desire most in a
transformers show
and it's clear that there are other
plans for the future now the mission
wants more remains to recover the old
spark but
things get confusing early on when our
core characters realize that the
maximals and predacons they meet on
earth
are from their future due to galvatron
appearing with the golden disc in earth
rise and a future version of megatron
traveling to the past
the timeline has been massively altered
and thus the heroes from the past and
future decide to team up once more in
order to stop a darker path from coming
to fruition
it's a lot of timely whimey wibbly
wobbly stuff that feels like days of
future fast and the furious
but as someone who loves time travel
stories and the idea of variants
i quickly jumped on board with this
finale i think that this is probably the
strongest entry in the trilogy
and though it's not newcomer friendly
they do enough to fill in the blanks for
those whose first time transforming
might be with this trilogy now things
are made worse as we learn the golden
disc contains the outcome of every
battle in megatron's future
it's basically the almanac from back to
the future and it makes failure
almost impossible for the villain as the
predacons and maximals both fight to get
the old spark
megatron uses his knowledge of the
future in an almost temporal pincer
strategy
and it makes him infinitely more
dangerous however
dinobot going turncoat does throw a
spanner in the works
as he manages to get the matrix in
episode 3 and he passes it to optimus
prime so the good guys can at least
counterbalance the villains
dinobot dies in one of the series most
heartbreaking scenes and though i was
expecting the character to have more
screen time in the series due to his
popularity
his impact doesn't go unnoticed i think
the main issue that the series has is
that it's trying to fit in as much
transform as lore as it can
and because of this some of the
characters are kind of pushed to the
wayside
this includes starscream and his
revolution as well as a leader who we
last saw on cybertron in the first
season
i was expecting her to have much more of
a role
but we'll talk about this later on in
the video now the matrix leads optimus
to a temple
in which the old spark is kept and he
gets a warning of nemesis prime
who becomes a pivotal character in the
finale megatron has clearly been
watching the heavy spoilers show through
the golden disc
and he heads to the temple in order to
get the old spark
this is where we learned that it was
actually then that megatron lost it
and this is why his future versions have
been trying to terminate in the past
and just make constant reboot after
constant reboot in the hopes of getting
one universe they can stick to now it's
led to the timeline looking like a
jackson pollock painting
and it will be interesting to see if
they prune all of the branches in the
future
in order to streamline the universe
though optimus is initially beaten at
the temple he's saved by optimus primal
and he receives a message from a vision
of a leader in which he says that
optimists must lose
throughout the entry we really see how
the constant war just leads to more war
and optimus even apologized to primal at
one point for creating a world in which
he was drafted into a never-ending
conflict
he allows megatron to win but this
backfires for the villain
and the sparks in the temple power up
the device we learn it shares a
symbiotic link with cybertron
and with the planet dying it too is
weakening after this the characters try
to return to cybertron but they're
attacked by the nemesis warship
however teletran arrives and saves them
at the last minute
optimus says goodbye to primal knowing
that their actions will likely wipe them
from existence
but we don't see this happen and i think
that due to the multiverse the paradox
is avoided
these characters will likely continue as
they come from an alternate timeline
and another example of this happens in
avengers end game when the heroes create
a branch in reality
that means nebula can kill nebula
without any issues
i think these characters will be okay
and as we don't see them disappear
it's likely that they'll be there to
fight unicron when he arrives
now they return to cybertron and find it
a snowy shadow of its former self
after making it to the temple of the old
spark optimus is devastated to learn
that a leader has been killed
prime of course blames himself and i
love how this chapter especially focuses
on how the characters past
and their futures all interlinked to
make this never-ending loop of war
during this time megatron comes face to
face with galvatron once more
who reveals that he is his future self
that has been enslaved by unicron
to make matters worse nemesis prime
shows up and we discover that he caused
the devastation on cybertron
now in case you don't know nemesis is
very much a black mirror of optimus
prime
and there have been a number of
incarnations of him his backstory has
been alternated between him being
either a clone of optimus or a machine
that was very much
molded in the shape of prime however
inward for cybertron he's the future
version of the character
and he's very much the result of prime
refusing to give up the quest to get the
old spark
this has completely corrupted him and
the finale very much becomes about
breaking the habits of the past in order
to save the future
we learn that nemesis prime and
galvatron eventually end up working
together
and that they want the old spark so that
they can destroy unicron
both he and galvatron come from a
timeline in which optimists didn't
return with the old spark
and thus they intervened and changed
things so that prime could come back
they want to restore their own timeline
and free themselves of the slavery
and optimus primal confirms this however
he says that they should make the most
of what they have
and make a stand it ramps up to a
brilliant finale in which we watch as a
crisis on infinite earths is very much
fought on the wasteland of cybertron
megatron realizes that he's not a slave
to his future and it's great watching
him turn from someone who was willing to
ravage cybertron
to someone who will fight for it no
matter what watching
all of the characters from the trilogy
and transformers lore makes a brilliant
last battle
and a leader returns after bumblebee
takes the old spark back to the temple
they stop galvatron and nemesis from
making it there and she tells prime she
loves him before calling him
orion in case you don't know before he
became optimus prime
the character was known as orion pax and
for fans of the franchise
i think this will be a very touching
moment due to the old spark being
returned
the darker timeline can be avoided but
that doesn't mean that now is the time
to rest
and optimus knows they must prepare for
the future though he attempts to make a
truce with the decepticons
megatron refuses but he decides to find
a place on the planet
in which they won't come across one
another starscream can still hear
unicron
and the season ends with us knowing that
the villain is now after this timeline
as the usage of traveling through the
dead universe has given him ideas
in space he absorbs both galvatron and
nemesis
and it's unlikely that they'll be
appearing in the next season now unicron
will of course become the big bad should
we get a sequel
and due to the final scenes here i think
more likely than not that netflix will
be continuing the transformers show
with a new series that carries across
the characters from this one
unicron is very much the devourer of
realities and
over the years he's had several creators
that have offered different takes on him
however this has all recently been
streamlined into one single continuity
for the character
which relies on something called the
multiversal singularity
now this means that there's actually one
unicron across the entire multiverse
and that it's only possible for it to
exist in one reality at a time
unicron then travels between these
realities feasting upon them one by one
and we know that he has enslaved
countless versions of other characters
in order to achieve his goals
now with galvatron and nemesis both
being defeated
i think that he will try a new tactic
and who knows how he will use the dead
universe to achieve his goals
i would actually love to see teletrans
stand up to him and i think that branch
from the normal timeline
does create a future fight in which he
could be going against the colossus
either way i think going forward that
the planet will have some peace for some
time
but with the arrival of unicron both the
decepticons and autobots will decide to
team up for the greater good
i'm really excited to see what happens
next and all in all it was a great
series
i have to say the ending of this one has
got me hungry for more and
that's not a unicron pun but yeah br
just bring us more please
now i think this was a really nice
ending and now some of the characters
got brushed to the side i still had a
lot of fun with it
and that's why it gets a 7.5 out of 10.
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the show and also
where you think things will be going in
the future comment below and let me know
and just to let you know
we're running a competition right now
and giving away three mcu box sets on
the 30th of august
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment with
your thoughts on the season
we pick the winners at random at the end
of the month and those who got the last
one are on screen right now
say that to you then message me on
twitter heavyspoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our latest breakdown of
the bad batch
which will be linked on screen right now
the star wars show is almost over and
there's a lot to talk about
so definitely go head over there right
after this if not then thank you for
sitting through the video
i've been paul and i'll see you next
time take care peace